I think the the measures that we've
announced are about doing what the
British people want us to do as a
government that's why the Prime Minister
made stopping the votes one of his core
five pledges at the beginning of the
year that's why I've been working pretty
much every day since I was first
appointed as Home Secretary on this uh
set of measures so whether it's
including uh whether it's introducing
new measures in legislation in our legal
migration Bill whether it's a new deal
with Albania pursuant to which we've now
relocated over a thousand people back to
Albania or whether it's our deal with
the French whether it's bearing down on
the backlog or whether it's new sites
for accommodating assignments on a whole
range of measures we've been working on
a plan that is going to fix this
unacceptable problem that being 45 000
people arriving here illegally last year
over six million pounds being spent a
day on Hotel accommodation that is an
unacceptable situation so this is what
the government is focused on at this
stage are you ruling out leaving the
ECHL
my personal views are are very well
known this government is not leaving the
eshr uh we have put forward measures to
ensure that we maintain uh some level of
power over our immigration policy that's
what the British people would expect we
need to be able to have the ability to
remove people to relocate people who
have come here illegally who've abused
our laws who have broken our rules and
who shouldn't be here yesterday the
immigration Minister said that
uncontrolled migration threatens to
cannibalize compassion in this country
by importing different Lifestyles what
do you think he meant by that
what he means is that unprecedented and
uncontrolled illegal migration is
placing unacceptable strains and
pressures on communities all around our
country whether it's a hotel which has
now been fully occupied by Asylum
Seekers whether it's
um uh the cost to the taxpayer whether
it's the criminality which is very
closely linked to many people coming
here illegally we see that there are
many people coming here illegally who
are then getting involved in drugs who
are getting involved in violent crime
who are getting involved in prostitution
all of that is at odds with British
values all of that is unacceptable
Behavior we need to deter people from
making the journey in the first place
that's why I encourage everybody to get
behind our measures in the bill so you
would think people that cross-channel
and small boats have different values to
the British public I think people who
come here in a small boat are behaving
unacceptably they should not be getting
in a flimsy plastic dinghy in the depths
of winter
at night putting their own lives at risk
sometimes putting other people's lives
at risk paying thousands of pounds to a
people smuggling gang in the hope of a
life in the UK that is not acceptable
behavior it is breaking our rules it is
abusing the generosity of the British
people and that's why we need to stop
the boats can I just get clarity on what
you mean when you say you want to stop
the boats because my understanding that
doesn't mean getting the number down to
zero anytime in kind of the short or
medium term
I think it will be very obvious uh to
reasonable observers as to whether we've
succeeded in our pledge to stop the
boats if you look at other countries who
have succeeded in challenges relating to
Illegal migration like Australia they
did manage to dramatically reduce the
number of illegal Maritime arrivals when
they delivered a scheme very similar to
the one that we are planning to so I
think stopping the boats is going to be
is very clear it's very simple uh what
it means and I think the British people
will understand when we when we achieve
that you say it's clear and simple will
you set a target for where you want the
numbers to be this time next year I
think it'll be very obvious to the
British people and the public as to
whether we've succeeded